la costumbre del círculo en el escenario
unos cuantos minutos antes de levantar
el telón las bailarinas y los bailarines
de la hoja meditan y gritan
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hacerse preguntas sobre el alcance
político del baile cartografiar las
formas coreográficas de sublevación
popular explorar nuevas dinámicas de
representación del cuerpo esto puede
parecer arduo austero y endemoniadamente
complicado pero no a la cabeza del
ballet nacional de marsella desde
septiembre de 2019 el colectivo lado
estos tres extraordinarios treintañeros
marine blood y jonathan de brawer y
aflojar el trabajan desde hace diez años
y repensando con películas o actuaciones
el baile todos los bailes tradicionales
clásicos o contemporáneos
reflexionamos juntos sobre nociones de
filosofía investigaciones orales
habladas sobre reflexiones alrededor de
lecturas para ver cómo el cuerpo puede
transmitir ideas simbólicas filosóficas
políticas y artísticas
en la nada de tus emilio tardos las 25
bailarinas y bailarines de la compañía
provenientes de 17 países diferentes no
respetan los cánones clásicos del arte
coreográfico
no pica en su donde lives hay king y abu
coches que ya nosotros hacemos con
frecuencia of cycling hay muchas cosas
que vienen del vintage eco de marcas
contemporáneas existentes que nos hacen
préstamos o nos ofrecen piezas para que
juguemos un poco con ellas
y entonces es una herramienta no de
decoración o que llega como una última
capa visual es algo que trabajamos antes
de nuestra escritura para darle sentido
y un lado personaje
y es lo que tratamos de despejar también
en nuestra pieza y salir un poco de una
visión académica del traje de danza para
alcanzar algo más narrativo y
cinematográfico
ponerse un traje también es afirmar
quién se es o transformarse o
reapropiarse entonces para nosotros la
danza era entrar en contacto con sus
diseñadores que son artistas para
nosotros y que reflexionan hoy en día
sobre lo que es un hombre lo que es una
mujer cómo se circula entre estas dos
realidades bien normadas que la sociedad
nos impone como a iluminar y edades que
tengan hoy y como se desplazan uno y
como se crean nuevos personajes y estos
nuevos personajes pasan por el arte y
llegan a la sociedad luego la sociedad
se desplaza entonces para nosotros ha
sido súper enriquecedor trabajar con
modistas o dicen ayer existir is true
the design a la ottt explora entonces
todas las posibilidades de
colaboraciones con entre otros
las marcas prêt à porter
para barber y coreografiaron con la
compañía del ballet nacional de marsella
sabrosas películas de moda
en el marco de las publicidades es una
colaboración con mega forest que es un
colectivo de directores y es cierto que
nosotros mismos que somos también un
colectivo de directores es un placer
poder encontrar de nuevo un terreno de
juego y experimentar y dirigirnos a
nuestros padres a grecia
vimos a nuestros padres de las
generaciones pasadas que tenían en la
casa en la que vivimos o la anp y tenía
colaboraciones increíbles con instant
lohan gianni versace o incluso pink
floyd en cuanto a música entonces es
cierto que para nosotros como
transdisciplinarios era natural
colaborar con diseñadores que imaginan
piezas trajes u otros directores con los
que compartimos nuestra práctica son
ante todo aventuras artísticas
hay que tener nuevos poetas y hay que
provocar eso hay que tener el deseo de
reunirse con el otro e incluso reunirse
con gente opuesta a nosotros así es que
podemos crear diálogo y nuevos
imaginarios
en cuanto a su fuente de inspiración
principal desarrollar un concepto
forjado por el filósofo francés michel
foucault en
1967 las heterotopías espacios concretos
ubicados en el interior de una sociedad
pero que no obedecen a las mismas reglas
suites por ejemplo encuadrar y suites
hablamos de deseo de fantasía todas esas
emociones fuera de tiempo y las
heterotopías son espacios que no
reaccionan al tiempo que nos rodea pero
que crean una dinámica una conciencia de
los otros lugares completamente fantasma
culecos y es cierto que en weber y
suites álamos la línea del deseo con
referencias a danzas populares danzas de
club danzas de seducción
diciendo las cosas claramente su nueva
pieza webber y suite podría contar
simplemente su encuentro durante los
años 2000 los tres fundadores de la oit
danzaban en clubs llamados safe space
espacios seguros parisinos donde los
artistas de las comunidades el gp y
cumas podían frecuentarse sin problema
es muy orgánico de hecho somos amigos
ante todo y entonces creo que tuvimos
ganas de crear momentos determinado
juntos en los que nos reunimos hablamos
entendemos un poco mejor el mundo de 3
agua
cambiando constantemente de punto de
vista afilando su espíritu crítico
cuestionando ese sin descanso la oit
persigue con gracia a la humanidad en el
caos de nuestro mundo actual